hello and welcome to co playing hi pooja
Enrique are paciente are Philippines
let's not the philippines right
singapore yeah singapore is a couple of
good players nowadays i think they
probably established some kind of
coaching there and gotten a couple of
good asian players to do to go there
think this all former chinese so when
Master Zhang Zhang Zhang is also in some
good single poor nowadays okay I'm just
playing some kind of very classical
looking Queens gambit see what happens
see em play this i QP kind of position
if i take i think i will take ya to kobe
6 here or night h 5 s's often a good
move here to make sure that this is
traded
it's difficult to do something if you
place d5 now just trading training the
game down and do nothing okay he didn't
do it so let's go up for Knight f6 check
yeah I'm trying to put the bishop on c6
here that's a good good square for it I
cannot go here and if we trade c6
against e4 should be okay for black ok
so it seems him don't want to do that
now we'll see usually usually the white
deep one is believed to be more of a
factor than my support let's see what
happens not sure if I've was typical
kind of quick move but a 4mm and a4 is
not ok ok trying to bring my night to be
six now
taking a five year that I have to okay
if I go Quincy seven then there's no not
be six coming soon okay then it just is
what it is where you should go buy a d5
hmm or maybe i should just reroute on
all the CM go no
and this is okay I was briefly worried
about 25 but I think this is all right
rooty six should be okay where's your
queen go hang the home and he said oh he
just texts hybrids I'm totally stupid
yet I just thought I thought I thought
that Raptor Queen Ian ok and the rook is
still attacked maybe there's something
we noted what an idiotic idea anyway
check it was a pretty good position by
the way i can see five know what to do
c5 I guess
and I'd be six Roxy 593 for book takes
rook chicks take their yeah it's George
but what time is not looking good
should speed up
one minute 26 the thing
Nance it's really quite Josh I wonder if
I if I can do something here probably
not okay ensure why did you allow that
could have just gone back on the
second-ranked gym it should win to pass
us candlelight resign very weird and
pretty pretty badly but I just blundered
a five I just bluntly named file I mean
this is an okay position this is really
ok ok Knight b6 was interesting and I
didn't see that Queen takes ok 8 25 and
now I can go here and yeah it's a good
end game very good end game and there
should be something because the B and D
porn are weaker than the CNA porn in
this position the bishop is not a very
good pc it just looks at this let's say
and it doesn't do much and what I did is
yeah it doesn't hurt but it also doesn't
do much good I simply thought he had
plundered the Queen so I should do
something like this problem and is equal
engine gives me a slight edge but it's
probably equal ish
okay well it's not so oops sorry of
course not this it's not easy to play
I've got can go there I can try for ever
and ever and ever him very likely he
will sit on some slightly was ending
yeah it here this is just bad check I
think this is this is very helpful rook
c8 computer wants to play this move
interesting this is the line for example
that is deciding and why there's a lot
better now there are a couple of things
like that did not know it should be a
draw did I got them porn back oops I
could have just taken age three year
while now I was a little bit too panicky
I think maybe with the time wanted to
play quick moves and here he just has to
still okay and I'll just go back goog
f2a King f2r um yeah just the draw no
now I'm winning the two points basically
promote to promote themselves there is
no big challenge there anymore Wow okay
thanks for watching